during the time period that we got this
situated there was one person who jumped
on board with me we had met at the
original groundbreaking of the Sundance
Institute back in 1979 81 was it that
was the first year I thought was 79 but
let me tell you Tommy and I got together
there and he became one of my closest
and dearest friends and an art artist
the profound effects Tom Bower thank you
always wanted to say this I want to
thank the Academy only taken us 35 years
to get here but look at this audience
yeah no we we met I met Eddie and Monet
and Bob and Michael Houseman at Sundance
the very first year of the Sundance
Institute film lab which was 1981 that's
on the record and because Malta had the
money from any a neh Corporation of
public broadcasting he had the story he
was generous enough because he was busy
with Milagro fee into your ward to say
you guys want to run with this well we
did Eddie brought Bob along and we set
in Eddie's backyard and cast all of our
friends the only guy we didn't know
beforehand was Bruce Bruce McGill and we
were super lucky to ever get him
and the rest of the people were mainly
people we had worked with a number of
times over a long period of time and I'm
sad to say that we're missing some of
our dearest friends
James gammon Tim Scott Allen Vint Brian
James who you will see in very prominent
roles here but for about two years
Eddy and I and others walked this around
the world giving away free screenings
until Norman Lear's company came along
and bought us and then we got to release
it for real but but you know since I've
been been a member of the Academy in
1987 I've come here to see everybody
else's films now we get to see the most
independent of all independent films up
here thank you one of the giant
producers of Latino stories in the world
if not in the country what the surest
partisan yeah I was a studio I loved
your studio bit go make the movie okay
I'll see you later bye he was a great
studio I didn't know I was working
really hard to keep the money flowing
they just said send more money I was
dying trying to get that money why did
you do it Missy I did it because there
were 5,000 mexicanos killed by the Texas
Rangers between nineteen hundred and
five at 1915 more mexicanos were lynched
and murdered by the Texas Rangers than
there were african-americans in any
other part of the south at that
particular moment in time that's why I
did it
I think that one of the most significant
things about this film is the way that
it speaks to us now how we see the other
you know whether we see them as an enemy
something to fear or we see a person
with compassion and understanding what
is it about this film made by all these
people that enables us to see a film and
feel that which is very hard to do it's
not easy it seems like like a simple
trick but it isn't I will share that
Edward James Olmos is completely telling
the truth I came to him and I said who
do you want to direct you this was
backstage at the Mark Taper Forum after
I saw him perform in zoot suit as a
Motoko and that was two years before we
actually got to make the movie and I
went back and I after having seen him
perform I knew that he had to be gonna
go to Yokota Thais that he was gonna go
to Cortese and that my job was to just
empower him so that's what I did
thank you thank you thank you to all of
you